LAKSHMI SHARMA: Hello, everyone.
Welcome to the
session on monitor
and troubleshoot your
network infrastructure
with data driven insights.
This is Lakshmi Sharma,
Director of Product Management
for Networking with my colleague
Irene Abezgauz, Product
Manager, working on
one of these products
that you will hear about today.
In this 20-minute
talk, we are going
to discuss the
common user journeys
during migration,
troubleshooting,
and optimization
of your network.
We will also demonstrate how
Network Intelligence Center,
the product that provides
you tools and capabilities
to support these user journeys,
is helping you by data insights
and offering a
platform that would
be used in most effective
ways throughout your user
journeys of infrastructure,
specifically
networking, troubleshooting,
migration, and optimization.
Network Intelligence
Center is a way
of offering you AI/ML powered
NetOps acceleration platform.
This is Cloud AI Ops in real,
working for your workloads
onto GCP.
Our goal is to become the
simplest Cloud to operate on
through an Intelligent
Self-Driving Network that
extends beyond GCP to hybrid,
to multi-cloud, to branches,
to places and capabilities that
you have built for operating
into virtual and Cloud
journeys, and also integrating
all the way to legacy
infrastructure and services
that are built on-prem
or any location
here henceforth I
mentioned, leveraging all
the AI and the data insights
that we continue to build
for building GCP and making
GCP the platform driven
by intelligent insight
and self-driving Cloud.
So Network Intelligence
Center is Google Cloud's way
of delivering onto that vision
of Self-Driving Network.
It contains multiple
modules to ensure
you can deploy what
you have intended to.
Basically, it gives you
tools for the deployment
to be matched to your intent.
It offers you troubleshooting
in any kind of performance
and connectivity issues
as you're migrating
or as you're operating
on the GCP, whichever
location, whichever place,
and whichever application
you have been running
currently or you
have been building towards.
It helps you optimize your
network, including firewalls
and other network services
and infrastructure services
that you will be using to
deploy your workloads onto GCP.
Networking is the foundation
for all Cloud deployments
and business processes.
We expect it to be up
and performing well.
Our customers expect it to be.
They want networking
to be seamless,
regardless of the use
case and the journey
that you are working towards.
User journeys
throughout Cloud, based
on our experiences of
customers migrating and working
on GCP with us, specifically
networking scenarios,
there are three
main categories--
planning and migration, day 2
ops at scale, and optimization.
So these are the three sets of
categories and user journeys
that we will be
taking it through,
and how different modules and
Network Intelligence Center
help you build and
drive towards that.
Here's what you need in
each of those stages.
Early stages,
deployment is live.
So when you're migrating your
network or your workloads,
while your deployment is live
what you want to make sure
is that what you intended to
do, what kind of architecture
you deploy for, is what you're
getting when you have migrated
or when you're migrating.
And then you also, once you
have measured configuration
and your intended
[INAUDIBLE],, then you really
want to make sure
that your traffic is
flowing as you intended to.
So that's kind of number one
in the early stages of our user
journey during
planning and migration.
The next step would be
that yes, I have migrated.
Yes, I have it as intended--
configuration and traffic
as intended, as I
expected it to be.
Now the second phase is
that, is it production ready?
Is it production live?
So that's the time when
you want to make sure
that your network
continues to stay healthy,
you are able to identify
and troubleshoot
issues in advance--
not at the time the issue
happens, but prior to
when the issue has happened.
Or in cases issue
has happened, you
being able to troubleshoot
it and identify the root
cause for each of those
issues in operation
or during production
operations very fast
and be able to remedy
it at an instant.
We also want to be able to
optimize your deployment.
You want to be able to optimize
your deployments that you're
running by having the control
on performance and cost.
First you want to be making
sure that your applications are
running with the
performance and reliability,
no matter what kind of
optimization that you make--
configuration
optimization, [INAUDIBLE]
optimization, and services
optimization, maybe
architecting it again.
So we give you a tool so
that you can optimize it back
and then you can go back
and check your intent again,
your traffic patterns
again, and you're back
to a very healthy
operation cycle.
So for all of
these user journeys
that we talked through, you need
a lot of data to be available.
You want your data to be
continuously monitored for you.
You want the control on where
my data is, where my logs are,
where my alerts are--
you want all of that information
across all your deployments
across these
stages, and you want
the data monitoring and
telemetry, everything
to be available to you so that
you start to make decisions
in a self-driving and
self-sustainable manner
without really any
interactions-- to be honest,
like, literally zero
interaction with people
on the other side of the Cloud.
So for all of these data, how
do we bring this data to you?
Network Intelligence Center
provides that visibility
into working on this network,
how the deployment actually
works, how and where the
traffic flows, and are there
or if there are any problems
and issues with configurations,
or the traffic, or the
routing-- any kinds
of [INAUDIBLE] or any anomalies,
or any suboptimalities that you
see.
So once we have all this
information for you,
the next step is for us
to provide users the tools
to make that data
easily available
and have the system
intelligently and then
automatically address
any existing issues,
as well as service the user the
most important things, the most
relevant insights.
We do want to avoid
the noise fatigue.
And after all, the network
is a business enabler.
We want your focus to be on
the most important and relevant
information.
It allows everything
else to communicate.
Network allows you to
communicate with your users.
Network allows
you to communicate
with your business processes
and your business people.
You want the network to
auto-resolve problems where
they're relevant, and to
service users any issues that
requires intervention.
That is why we are working
on enhancing [INAUDIBLE]
capability across different
services and capabilities
that we have in
networking to deliver
the most important
information to our users
across all these
journeys that you put
in a timely and concise manner.
So we want to be
going from a place
where you're
planning, migrating,
writing your architecture,
you're making sure
that your intent is
right, then you're
automating and optimizing
toward for your performance
and reliability and cost.
Once you have
delivered this cycle,
we want the [INAUDIBLE]
to be working with you so
that you are able to deliver.
And you want these
capabilities to be
delivered in a self-driving,
self-contained manner to you.
So Day 2 Ops.
Day 2 Ops capability, which
you see in the middle,
are what we are focusing in now.
And you will see some
capabilities and planning
and migration state
in Day 2 Ops case
so that you are able to leverage
our products and capabilities
today while we bring
you onto the journey
of eventual optimization and
self-driving capabilities.
IRENE ABEZGAUZ:
Thank you, Lakshmi.
So basically, when we
listen to the users,
they emphasize the
following thing.
We want the network
to be up and running.
It needs to be available, and
it needs to be performing,
and we have a business to run.
We don't need to deal
with anything else.
And essentially, it needs
to be up and running.
If it breaks, we want to
know as soon as possible.
Now, this needs to happen
regardless of what's
happening with our traffic.
It can be spiky.
In a nice way to say it, it
could be dynamically changing.
And in those conditions,
we need to be
able to monitor the network.
And essentially,
that's what the users
have been saying that
Network Intelligence
Center has been giving them.
And I think the best example,
or the best quote that I
got from this, from one
of our users, was, listen,
we're used to aggressively
monitoring everything on-prem.
Now, you take our most
precious workloads
and you put it on this
magical mystery black box,
and we don't want
to lose visibility.
We cannot afford
And that really
resonated with me, maybe
with the tiny exception
of not wanting
to bring SNMP to the Cloud
unless I really have to.
But with the exception
of that, I really
believe in that-- as much
data as possible, and as much
visibility as possible.
Now, let's jump right
in and take a look
at the modules of the
Network Intelligence Center
and how they're used
in the user journeys
that Lakshmi has described.
The first place where
users typically start
is Network Topology.
Basically, they come here when
you've just migrated something,
or you've created
something from scratch.
Now, there is a
new thing, and you
want to make sure that whatever
it is that you've built,
that it matches your intent.
Are those the servers
that I wanted to have?
Are they communicating in
the way that I expected?
How is traffic following?
How is it flowing?
Are the relevant
regions being served
from relevant continents?
Do I have any inter-regional
communications
that I'm not supposed to have?
Am I bypassing load balancers
when I shouldn't be?
All those things
are basically things
that you see in
Network Topology,
with the addition of being
able to see performance
metrics on the edges.
Now, from here, if you're
trying to get more information,
there is actually a direct
pivot from Network Topology
into VPC Flow Logs.
So if you are looking
at a specific server
at a specific edge, and you
want to get more Swiss knife
kind of information,
you can just
go directly from
here into VPC Flow
Logs in the relevant context
and see what's happening.
Now, in Network
Topology, you can
see compute instances,
load balancers, connections
to on-prem, Cloud APIs.
We are going to add GKE
infrastructure support.
And that's essentially Topology,
typically used in migration
or where something changes.
Now, the next thing is
the Performance Dashboard.
This is where you end
up when things are not
going quite as expected.
Usually, when you see
there is a problem
or you suspect the
problem, you'll go here.
And here, you can actually see
packet loss and latency metrics
for traffic in your projects.
There is a combination here of
synthetic traffic and sampling
of actual user traffic
of your machines.
You will see here only zones,
regions where you are deployed.
And you can essentially see
your own specific performance.
Now, one thing that we
have recently launched
is the Global
Performance Dashboard.
In many cases, when
there is a problem
and you get to the
Performance Dashboard,
the question you're
going to ask yourself
is, OK, something is
not going as expected.
I'm seeing high latency, or
I'm seeing high packet loss.
OK?
For that matter, is the problem
anywhere in my deployment,
or is it a Google
Cloud-wide kind of problem?
And having those two Performance
Dashboards side-by-side
basically lets you compare
your project performance
to the performance
of all of Google.
And then you can know whether
there is a network outage,
or maybe there is just a few
servers choking somewhere--
100% CPU-- and that is the
reason why they're not properly
responding to requests.
Any Google-wide
outages are going
to be very clearly visible
on both dashboards.
And obviously, when you pivot
from your project to this one,
you'll be able to see where
is the source of that problem.
Now, as I said, we are going
from relatively high-level--
OK, I just upgraded.
Please tell me in high-level
how everything looks,
because I'm trying to understand
the connection between things.
And from there, you
can actually drill down
to very specific metrics.
As I said, it really actually
depends on the type of user.
Right?
Some users, they're
going to say,
listen, just throw all
the information you can.
I'm going to derive all
the insights myself.
Just give me all
the data possible.
I'm just going to plug it
into a third-party system,
or I'm going to process it.
And I want to see raw data.
And other types
of users are just
going to say, please
crunch everything for me,
and please only call me if
it's super critical, super
important, and you're
absolutely sure that this
requires my attention.
Now, for the kind
of users who want
to see everything and want
to get this visibility,
there in-Cloud monitoring.
There are very specific
product metrics.
You can see, for example, for
every VPN in every project.
You can see the state
of the VPN tunnel.
Are there any issues?
You can see whether the
tunnel is up or not,
have there been any
Handshake problems,
what's the throughput?
For Interconnect as
well, you can see
the status of the attachment.
You can see the throughput.
You can see the throughput
over a period of time.
Essentially, you can go from
very kind of high-level,
this is your Topology, to
very, very specific details.
And I think this is the goal
of really providing something
that we can proudly
call data-driven, right?
OK, here's all the data.
And you can crunch it yourself,
or we can crunch it for you
and get to a point.
Now, another-- this
is actually one
of the favorite
products by our users,
saving a huge amount
of support calls.
And it goes like this.
Give me endpoint A.
Give me endpoint B.
And this product checks whether
the configuration allows
connectivity between
these two endpoints.
This means essentially, if
you're looking at VM to VM,
nodes to master, VM to Cloud
SQL, on-prem to Cloud SQL,
is your configuration actually
allowing this connectivity?
And then if it's not
allowing this connectivity,
basically, this module
is going to tell you
there is a firewall
rule blocking it,
or you have a routing issue.
Now, these look
at configuration.
And what we have just
recently launched
is dynamic connectivity
tests, which
for quite a few
of the scenarios,
they also look at
what's actually
happening on the data plane.
OK, so your configuration
allows connectivity.
Now let's take a deeper dive
and look at the metrics.
What is the latency
between these two?
What is the packet loss ratio,
if any, between these two?
You have the connectivity
test to basically tell you
whether any two
endpoints are able to
or should be able to
for configuration,
and are actually able to
connect and talk to each other,
and how that
connection looks like.
Now, Network Intelligence
Center has additional modules,
like Firewall
Insights, for example.
That's going to tell you whether
you have unused firewall rules,
or any additional information.
So there is quite a
lot there that you
can go and actually check out.
And a quick recap.
In this not-very-long
presentation,
we've talked about what we have
seen to be the typical user
journeys when users
are migrating,
when they're actually
operating at very large scales,
and when they're trying
to do optimization.
And now, since this
is a recorded session,
I want to share with you
some of the questions
that we're usually being
asked, and the answer to these.
Probably the most
common question
I get is, what about GKE?
And the answer is that yes,
essentially, the Performance
Dashboards show the
performance for GKE cheeky
workloads as well.
We have GKE connectivity
in Connectivity Test.
As I mentioned, in
Topology, we are
working on showing the
GKE infrastructure.
That is a big part
of the workloads that
are running on Google
Cloud, and that's definitely
something to be covered.
We're also looking at
serverless-- for example,
not just GKE.
Again, the same support.
You have Topology.
You have Connectivity Test.
So there's quite a lot
that you can learn.
This is definitely
not just for Compute.
Another super common question,
especially by the larger
organizations, is how does this
fit into my existing processes,
because I am hybrid, because
I'm the Cloud, because I already
set up a thing, and
I want to continue
using that thing, which
makes a lot of sense?
So basically, we're looking
at it from two aspects.
One aspect is taking all the
information in the Network
Intelligence Center
and making it
available to be consumed
programmatically.
So you can grab it via API.
You can plug it into
your own systems.
So you can trigger any sort
of response based on alerts,
for example, which you've
set, and so on and so on.
The other one is that the
combination of Network
Intelligence Center
and Cloud Monitoring
basically allows you to
see all your monitoring
in a single place.
Last question, as I see
we are approaching time,
is can this be used
for compliance?
And that's actually one of
the major goals of the Network
Intelligence Center.
You can see where
traffic is flowing,
or for [INAUDIBLE]
purposes, you can see
where traffic is not flowing.
You can get VPC Flow
Logs on the trail.
You can get screenshots
that you can then
use in compliance reports.
So there is actually quite a lot
in mind in terms of compliance,
and quite a lot that
the Network Intelligence
Center can deliver.
This team is always available
for any additional questions
that you may have.
There is also quite
a lot happening
in the Next '21
networking sessions,
and I do encourage you to
go ahead and take a look.
Thank you.